j'ai annoncé dans une interview que
j'allais arrêter dans deux ans tpm paix
directes car plein de fans
et voilà et de gens sur sur les réseaux
sociaux qui m'ont dit ouais cyril ta
tube arrêté dans deux ans qu'est ce que
c'est que cette histoire
tout ça alors je vais vous dire je pense
que j'ai dit une grosse connerie ah
voilà énorme si riche et d'écrire
sonnerie ouais merde oui parce qu'ils
voulaient prendre ma place et
franchement j'arrêterai con quand on
arrêtera de vous amuser
quand vous serez beaucoup moins à nous
regarder et comme on dit tous les fans
ils m'ont dit cyril c'est pas toi de
dire quand tu arrêtes c'est à nous de te
dire
donc ils ont raison donc j'ai dit ça
c'était une connerie bien entendu et on
verra je sais pas si j'arrive dans deux
ans dans trois ans dans cinq ans dans 22
ans
ou bien peut-être dans un mois mais
voilà c'est vous qui déciderez bien
entendu si les fans chinois
merci les séries